- You know like being a
thought leader is crippling
to people because they think
they have to be a leader.
I think it's being a
thought contributor, right?
So the reason I hate
when people are like oh,
you have to be a thought leader,
I'm like no you don't, you have
to be a thought contributor.
Now at its worst is what we
see on social media every day,
which is people pontificate
as keyboard warriors
about shit they don't know.
At best I think it's all
of us being very self-aware
and deploying what we know.
This portion is like with me,
so I think this is when one
you need to get selfish,
like you ask your question.
(upbeat music)
Hiring is guessing, firing is knowing.
Like you gotta go fast,
that's how you get shit done,
that's out figure stuff out.
This is the television and
the television is the radio.
The 4Ds mother fuckers.
- My first question is
how do I gain the trust
with ad agencies or anything
if I'm not actually producing the content?
I'm more so like the project
manager/account manager--
- By reverse engineering what they value,
so you may not be able to for some shops.
- Sure.
- For other shops just
getting the volume of output
at a cost that allows them to make margin
is what they care about.
I think one of--
- Budget turnover.
- Yeah, so I think what you
need to do is make sure,
this will play for several
people in the room,
I think one of the biggest
mistakes that companies make
in agency landscape and SAS
products is wasting time
on selling to the unsellable.
I'm just fascinated by people's ideology
that they want this customer
as if that customer is any more valuable
than the other person
that pays $6.99 a month
because they made it emotional.
To me the best way to sell
something is to be unemotional
and go fast and so there
will be many people
that don't want to do business
with you because of that
and there will be many people
that don't give a shit.
What you need to do is
spend as little time
trying to convince and
as much time as you can
finding the ones that are aligned, yep.
Makes sense?
- Yeah, totally.
- I'll let you sneak one more
in because that was quick
and then we'll get the third,
we're gonna try to go around
as many times as we can.
- Pretty much I guess again
me just now starting out,
how do you approach people
trying to share your post
or leave a comment you know
and that type of thing?
Like do you approach
friends and friends share
or is it you're trying to
get your target audience?
- You know I think there's a
lot of different points of view
and obviously there's
a platform being built
just down the table to like help scale,
but to me the thing
that we'll spend time on
when I get to her is like
I don't think all posts
are created equal and so to me
you have to be agenda driven
so for me I think it's more about
you joining Facebook groups,
you creating LinkedIn creative,
which I think will work for a lot of you
and then target with
AdSpend against agencies
and you replying thoughtfully.
You should map every single
CEO that is a creative shop
that you want to do business with,
follow her or him on every platform
and then thoughtfully leave a comment
of two to three sentences to every post.
I genuinely believe depth
wins the social game not width
and I think everyone's buying into width
so for me I think that's how you do it.
- Okay.
- I think you create your best thoughts
and put them out and I
think you community manage
AKA leave creative comments on things
that you think resonate in your world.
- Okay, cool.
- I apologize real quick.
I'll give you an example.
Just leaving some thoughtful
point of view on photography
under the creative lead
of a 15% agency in Dallas
leads to business development
for you because she sees that
and she's like who's this woman, you know?
- Or even add other people that follow her
when I see it on the comments.
Cool, thanks.
- But where everybody
fucks up in my opinion is
they go for scale not depth,
so like I see a lot of people
buying automation tools
to like people's posts just 'cause
they think that gets them awareness.
Like a lot of short tactics
that are good for vanity
metrics for five minutes,
but terrible for business.
- Okay.
- So one thing we run into in our industry
is people are pretty
cagey with saying that
they're using a certain
product or you know,
they wanna keep everything
close to the vest,
but we found referrals word-of-mouth
and people asking who are
other users are to be the fastest sales.
So kind of--
- I would turn that into creative
and pump a living shit
out of that on LinkedIn.
You know, what's that?
- Well I just as far as
like writing articles or--
- Yep.
Audio yep, video yep.
I think you know one of
the things, so for example,
I think and this is really
a fun time to say it
'cause it's two posts ago or three now
if you look at my Instagram
there's a cartoon.
Now my cartoons or comics or
whatever you want to call 'em
have done quite well.
Ironically the one that's
posted three posts ago
is one of my least performing
posts in a long, long time,
which is perfect because
it lets me make my point.
The answer is yes to everything,
which is why no matter
what you were gonna say
I was and say yes and I was
gonna do what I just did
because the reality is,
is that people consume
content differently
and so like the reason,
the number one goal you have
is to eliminate friction
for the person you're
trying to sell to at scale.
LinkedIn, which is something
I didn't talk about at all
until like 18 months or 12 months ago,
the reason it's coming so
much out of my mouth right now
is it's the first platform since Facebook
that has so much organic scale,
like you have no brand,
you've done nothing,
and you can literally
write an article about
why you think Boca is a
good market to invest in,
why you're somebody good to
invest in, why the Boca school,
my recommendation think like a publisher
not like a selfish salesperson.
Why the Boca school
system is up-and-coming,
because you know, whatever it may be.
That post for you with
no presence on LinkedIn
is gonna be seen by way more people
than you can ever imagine.
There is no platform right now
that gives free organic reach
with no paid support even remotely close
to face, to LinkedIn.
And even the fact that I
almost just said Facebook
was really interesting to me an insight
because it was the only other place,
like it used to be search on Google.
Like if this was a meeting in 1999
I would be yelling at all
of you and be like okay,
so is this new thing called SEO
and you have to figure out
how to be number one on it,
fuck the yellow pages, like you know?
It's all been one game of that.
Where can you get the most
awareness for the least?
LinkedIn.
It's really uncomfortable.
Now for you you're so specific
that I would actually spend the ad money
to target people in the art business
and all of you can do that.
The ads are a little more
expensive on LinkedIn,
but they're stunningly targeted.
What I like is you've already
figured out what works.
Some of us don't know yet.
Now you turn those
testimonials into creative,
but find a way to make the testimonial
feel less like an infomercial at night.
So you have to be, I'll
give you a great example.
I am gonna give you this
one, I think this would kill.
Get five of them, three of them,
in literally radical candor.
Email them and be like
hey, we're about to do
some Linkedin content
but instead of asking you
to do a video for me, testimonial,
I'd like to invite you
and four of my other
high-quality clients to dinner.
I wanna buy you a nice dinner,
we're gonna have some
nice bottles of wine,
and we're gonna talk about
the art industry as a whole
and I'm gonna film it and then do chop ups
and then put it on LinkedIn.
Then as the hostess,
you'll talk about macro,
but you'll find ways to integrate things
about your business, which inevitably
will lead to some great quote.
You know, Johnny says, "Fuck,
"yeah we used to fuck that up before you."
Got it?
- Yeah.
- So what I'm very good at and
actually this is very meta.
This right now is more for the content
than what you're paying
our company to be here.
Just is.
This is not, especially running it
through Vayner and all the overhead,
not the best use of my time financially.
It's I want the questions and the content.
If you look at how much of the content
I've been putting out the
last year is from 4Ds.
This puts me in a good
position to create a new idea.
The flub of Linkedin and
Facebook, Dustin can now quote
and that could be a two million viewed
because that's an
interesting piece of content.
I looked at him earlier when
I said something to you,
I can't remember like the
depth width thing, you know.
So even like literally
the advice I'm giving you
I'm living in the meta right now.
Create environments, this can lead to,
by the way, this could lead
to why you would do an exhibit
at your best friends
gallery about your product,
strictly about the subject
of the business of art,
but you're filming it, boom.
Got it?
- Yeah.
- It's really interesting.
I want to get everybody
to think like a publisher.
I need to make you
think like art magazine,
like Real Estate Investment monthly.
Like Vogue, not like the company you are
'cause then you go from a
commercial to quality content
that actually people want
and then if I tell you
where to put it that's under priced,
that's the story of my life.
That's who I am, that's how I got here.
Bring value and figure out
where it's under priced,
so you get the maximum
amount of brand equity from.
This LinkedIn thing is a dream
because it's a business context world,
but it's acting like Facebook.
And everybody's being
successful, it's crazy.
I'm getting emails.
It reminds me of early,
it definitely will work.
So that's what I would do.
Plus then you're also doing retention.
You're buying a nice dinner for, right?
You're like you're
winning on so many fronts.
Like people don't do a
good job with farming,
they do a good job with hunting,
more customers, more customers.
But they don't do a good enough job saying
thank you to the ones they got.
- So as I mentioned before,
my company is basically in the infancy.
I'm trying to just get
my toe in the water.
So my first question I guess is
where would you start if you were me?
- And this is the concept
of not wanting to be
at the mercy of brokers
selling your properties?
- Selling my property but
also leasing the space--
- From a commercial standpoint?
- Yeah.
- But this is strictly on
that side of it, right?
This is not to raise
capital from investors?
- So basically my plan is to
do a couple deals and then raise money.
- Understood.
And you have some inventory?
- Yeah, I have about 300,000
square feet of office space.
- In Boca and Jersey?
- Yeah.
- Understood.
And so to me I think you're barking up
a really interesting tree
and it's something I think a lot about,
because I think it's
quite a lucrative space
because there's so much margin
being made by the brokers
and there's no innovation
being done by the developers.
I started giving you previews of it.
Couple things.
Based on that square footage,
first, you have the reverse engineer
who's likely to rent from you.
So is this localized or
is this at such scale
that we're looking for national players?
- So they're basically
different kinds of buildings.
The one has got 20,000
square foot floor plans
where I have like Geico
and big institutional,
where I still would think it's local
at least to Central Jersey.
Might go to South Plainfield
or towns in the neighboring area,
but it's pretty localized.
And then Boca is the opposite,
I have like 60 small offices from 500
to maybe 3,000 max, 4,000 max.
And so they're like
local business owners--
- So there's two ways
for everybody to go here,
it's a good time to put it into play.
We've gone down the path of
more of content as a publisher.
You either want to become the magazine
or the guy or gal they put
on the front of the magazine.
And if you think about it,
that's what I've done both of,
right, for my companies
we're the magazine.
For me, Gary Vee, I'm
the one on the cover.
You're a reserved dude,
but I never think that
that's a prerequisite to
building a personal brand.
My biggest fear is that I
believe building personal brand,
which I view is not charlatan,
but more like having a reputation in 1947.
I always worried that if I'm
the messenger of that advice
that people think that they
should do it the way I do it,
which is very hyperbola,
my energy is pretty over-the-top.
That's my natural energy when
I'm on camera or on stage,
but I think that you have
to make a decision of
one or the other or both.
And by the way, that goes
for both of you as well.
Being a thought leader
is crippling to people
because they think they
have to be a leader.
I think it's being a thought contributor.
So the reason I hate
when people are like oh,
you have to be a thought leader.
I'm like no you don't,
you have to be a thought contributor.
Now at its worst is what we
see on social media every day,
which is people pontificate
as keyboard warriors
about shit they don't know.
At best I think it's all
of us being very self-aware
and deploying what we know.
So you're a young, is this
a business you started
as a family business, what is this?
- [Man] Yeah, so it started
as a family business
and basically I just spun off on my own.
- Understood.
So like that's was my
intuition given the scale
or some other unusual reasoning.
That's a huge advantage for you.
You get to--
- I'm only 28.
- Right and so you get
to lean in and say look,
this is, you know like I think
that's an incredible thing
to like lean into, which is
you have something I had at 28,
which is at 28 years old I
knew everything about the wine
and spirits business
because I've been doing it
since I was 14 and I was
doing it passionately
and I gave up school and social
life to be the best at it.
And so by the time I was 28 I was fucking,
by time I was 28 I was done actually.
I'd achieved what I set out to do at 22.
I built one of the largest
independent stores.
I built a big business for my dad
and I was ready to kind of actually start
transitioning into something else.
That's why Wine Library TV
and all this other stuff
started happening which
led to the Gary Vee
that we know today and so I think
that's an incredible
place for you to play,
but you have to be self-aware
and you don't have to
build a personal brand.
If we're gonna build it
through the company's name
'cause you're more comfortable with that
then I think you need to
produce a show or content.
Either a running podcast, which again,
doesn't even have to be you.
Preferably you because when you lose
the star that's a problem.
I think it's has,
So Boca I'm very interested
in, I'll tell you why.
I think if you started a podcast called
The Boca Small Business
Forum, you would crush.
This is something might
everybody I know, Nick,
and I know you guys have
heard this multiple times.
The high school party concept,
which is if you host it,
you have the leverage.
So I was always fascinated.
Alan Shaubauer, big shout out Alan,
did it in my high school.
Took advantage of his
parents not being around,
threw the parties, went from a C-plus,
he was be B-minus when he first came,
but went right to an A popularity
'cause he hosted the party.
Again, whether it's you or
some other way you do it
if you have the Boca Business Podcast
and you now are inviting other businesses
like the queen bee that's
been there for 54 years
is the baker or the real
estate agent or whoever.
The guy who's got the sailing company,
like you host a party,
within five, six months
you have the podcast at every
SMB in Boca is listening to,
aspiring to be on, but
what it really becomes is
a gateway drug to you
leasing out your space.
You don't have to mention it
once and you'll lease it out.
You don't have to mention it once,
they're just gonna be
like who is that kid?
Oh he owns a lot, you know?
Like it's so, I always tell people
let your profile do your selling.
Put out a lot of value in your content.
If people like it they're gonna click
your URL in your Instagram.
Let your profile do your selling.
So I think those are the
themes that I'm thinking.
- [Man] And the platform you suggest?
- I love the idea, you guys haven't done
the personal brand part yet?
Like the content tree?
So I will push everybody to podcasts,
like you would not believe.
Even more than video because I think video
is a bigger mental and
infrastructural jump for many.
I love podcasts because of the following:
you do a podcast, you film the podcast,
which gives you video.
You get the guests audience
when they're a guest,
because they're gonna promote
it bringing you awareness.
I'm obsessed.
- [Man] And so how would you
come up with content for this?
- Interview, that's the best part.
I'm good at what I do and
do something almost no,
if you look at the top 100 podcasts
outside of like shows that
are scripted like Serial,
the amount of individual
humans who have a podcast
where they don't interview somebody
in the top 500 is almost non-existent.
It's like me and I haven't
done enough homework,
but like maybe, just not a lot.
I'm trying to think who does
a straight-talking no other guests.
I don't know, nonetheless.
Podcasts are fucking lay up.
Especially if you go my route and level up
and make it broader.
The Boca Business Podcast.
The first person can be the
fucking third generational guy
who's 58 who owns the boat company in town
that's been crushing for years
and when you email him
on LinkedIn or his email
and say, "Hey John, do you
want to be the first guest
"on the Boca Business Podcast?"
The answer is yes, because
John's not being asked
by anybody to be on a podcast.
Got it?
And then literally the
content's of piece of cake.
So John tell us about how you got started.
So John what's happening now?
How's Boca changed in the last,
like you're fucking 40 minutes
done before you even started.
Asking four questions and going to sleep.
- Yeah so what do you think, you know,
about maybe expanding to Palm
Beach county so that we have--
- Yep, fuck to be frank,
depending on your ambitions
and skill set, make it Florida.
- Yeah, South Florida or something.
- I'll push you to America,
I just need to know what
your ambitions and capabilities are.
Does that make sense?
- [Man] Yeah.
- I love hyper local,
because I think it
creates depth of results
in a very narrow place.
But I love national if
you've got the juice, go.
You know?
Then you put the podcast
on all the platforms,
which is very easy, you can
google it, or we can tell you.
That's just like record, upload,
Spotify, SoundCloud, iTunes, Stitcher.
But then if you record it and
let's get it straight here.
For the first eight years of
my career I didn't have a team.
So the way I would have done it is like
I would have to have my iPhone
on the table and recorded it.
And then literally posted the
raw fucking video on LinkedIn.
So you know people,
again, being the messenger
of a lot of these things
right now scares me,
because I have a level of notoriety now,
leverage, infrastructure,
but I got here by doing
what I'm telling you to do.
- So in another life I
was a rock N' roll DJ.
- Amazing.
- My last gig was broadcasting
to 20 million listeners a day for XM.
That's crazy.
- So I have some of that--
- That in you.
- Yeah.
- That's good I mean
look, that's as you know,
like to me I hope people
don't shy away from that.
You should triple down on that.
It's the top of the funnel.
- I do.
- Good.
- Whether it's pitching or
vlogging or interviews we do it--
- Good, good.
- Which is great, like
my team calls me Kalee,
Kalee from (mumbles)
- I love it.
- So I have a couple questions.
I'm making one short 'cause we--
- No worries.
- One is I do a video of the day
in addition to other video,
this is a minute long roughly
and it goes to our Facebook profile,
mostly exclusively, sometimes else where.
It's just me holding my phone and I say,
"It's a day in the life of
a start up entrepreneur."
- Love.
- And I share--
- Whatever, today I was at VaynermMedia.
- Yeah, exactly.
And it's usually some
kind of real deep insight
so one of the things
that I love about radio
and podcasts is pulling
back the black curtain
and giving people that access to,
that's where the Theater
of the Mind comes into me.
Of course I've been in
a million green rooms
so I like that and I've learned that
my audience likes that as well.
So we use that video to give people
that behind-the-scenes
look of what it's like.
And it's female entrepreneurship is hot--
- Of course, of course, which is great.
- So we sometimes put it on Instagram.
Once in awhile if it's
super short on Twitter
but I'm I'm thinking
about LinkedIn of course.
- You have to put it everywhere
you know that, right?
- Well the LinkedIn we haven't
because I'm concerned--
- You have to put it everywhere,
contextually post produced for everywhere.
- Yes and here's why I haven't on LinkedIn
and this is what I'm going to ask
because it sometimes is
not very investor friendly
because sometimes I'm really honest.
That's where they all are.
- No.
- Just do it?
- Yeah, that to me is like cool.
First of all, let me
give you great advice.
Any investor that won't
want to invest in you
because it's not investor friendly,
is not somebody you would
have won with anyway.
It's not your DNA.
It's like me thinking about that shit.
Got it?
- [Woman] Just put it out there.
- You want to hear something even better?
It's gonna help you.
What its gonna actually do
is keep those investors away,
which is gonna save you three
to eight bullshit meetings
that are going to cost
you time in the future.
It's probably gonna make the investor
that you actually want come to you
instead of you going to her or him.
You understand?
- [Woman] Yes.
- This is a big game of wanting nos
and that's where everyone's
getting confused.
Think about what I'm doing.
I'm super not friendly
to a lot of things too.
Patriot fans don't want to work with me,
people that don't like cursing.
- [Woman] So it's easier.
- So it really will help you.
- [Woman] Okay, thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Man] So first question, so
the construction industry's
rather behind when it comes to technology.
- That's your advantage.
- Yeah, so how do we sell
to the companies and--
- It's similar to what I gave her.
- Big companies, the Relateds,
the Skansas, the you know?
- Well those companies
because I know with Related,
they're super sophisticated.
- [Man] Oh yeah.
- So they're not behind,
like to me the biggest companies
will judge you on merit
like what are they using alternatively?
Whether there's a direct
competitor or not.
Is there a legacy tech competitor,
which everybody deals with?
Like did with Resy with OpenTable.
We just had a really big
exit to American Express.
Big win for us.
We had to deal with OpenTable.
There was a legacy and that was bad.
Restaurants were further
along, had infrastructure,
but we innovated and
made a better product.
Other things, Buddy
Media, back to your world,
like an investment that I did well with.
Not even, I gave a quote to
and got a lot of shares
and did extremely well.
Mike Lazaro won because it was first,
but he got a lot of nos, like Vayner.
Vayner got an ungodly
amount of nos 2009 to 2014.
Just 'cause people didn't
even believe in social.
Now they believe in it,
but they look at it in
different ways and our nos
come from the way they look at it,
not don't believe in it at all.
Related and others are
sophisticated enough
to know if there is technology.
Is an Excel sheet and a piece of paper
better than paying you?
Or are you perfect?
I think the long tail is
where it gets a little bit
more interesting where there is pushback.
- Because a lot of the
people that are in the fields
are old school and they like
to do things the old school way
and they don't, even if
the technology is good,
they're just stubborn
and don't want to use it.
- It's the story of human beings.
Every industry has that.
My dad didn't take credit cards
or have a computerized
register when I first started.
- [Man] I use it.
- Right, you have their
patience for the 28 year olds
to take control or you need to be smart
and not bang your head
against the steel pillar
to the people that won't
say no and find the five.
What I'd be looking for, I
would do homework on this,
if I was your partner I
was like okay, sales plan.
Hey, 'cause I've come in
and I don't know anything,
I'd be like hey, can we get
somebody to get a list of
every family, family-centric organization
that already now has the daughter or son
that's under 40 in the business.
Give me that list.
I'd be like okay then, then
I would look at that list
and like okay, in order
of size or close to us
and be like alright let's go the Martinis
because Sarah Martini is now
in the business, she's 29,
we've done the intel, she's worked there.
She left, she went to business school,
she came back to the
family biz, she's there.
She inevitably is gonna be
more open to this conversation.
The end.
- [Woman] And they're all named in sense.
- Right.
(laughing)
I met one of their daughters
the other day, good company.
Yeah, it was awesome.
Old school dude and three
daughters, they would fucking,
I was like literally my first
piece of advice for them
was like you need a show on Bravo.
(laughing)
Fuck the construction company.
- And you would put content,
like what kind of content?
Saving money, saving time?
- No, yes, but I would make jokes.
- [Man] Make it comedic and funny and--
- I have found a lot of success in areas
that are more like what I come,
I come from the liquor business.
I come from the construction business,
we just didn't build
things, we sold liquor.
It was that and I think
one of the fun things about
those real old-school businesses is jokes.
I would probably, I'd
never give this advice
but I'm giving it to you,
I'd probably get some
NYU actors and actresses
and literally reenact scenes
from the field that are just
cliche that could go viral
within the community.
It's funny, I got really upset
the other day at the airport
because somebody was being really rude
to an airline employee and
just sometimes things click
and I made this video,
it was super narrow.
I'd go pretty general with
my content these days,
but it was like airline employee stuff
so we posted it, we did
whatever, it did fine.
I think pretty solid actually for narrow.
- [Man] Yeah, we ran ads too.
- Ran some ads against
employees of that world
because I can tell you right
now I ran through LAX yesterday
and fucking was like
put on, I think I could,
like it was unbelievable.
Like 20 different airline employees
were like oh, thank you so much.
(laughing)
It like penetrated the subculture,
so I think you're one funny
video away from cliche.
All of us are picturing
the guys in the video now
doing some dumb shit on a piece of paper,
the wind comes along and takes the pic,
like just literally reenact
or do it in cartoon form.
I think it would work.
Facebook will work for you
because that community's on that platform.
- Because I was thinking about maybe
possibly putting out like
some nostalgic type content
where it kind of hits to the old-timers
who think of the construction--
- I actually think the old-timers,
I think the old-timers are your problem.
I think you're making
content for 28 year old Sally
and for the decision makers
in comedic form and information form.
Save money, same time, they know that.
The 32 year old CFO in all these companies
or accountant you know, they know.
They just don't have the
leverage to make the move.
But they make the call.
Like ultimately in these cliche examples,
junior, sons makes the call.
You're not gonna win fucking
63 year old Sal ever.
- [Man] They're not gonna change.
- Fuck you.
Computer, that's all bullshit.
You see these hands?
(laughing)
Right, you know, you know.
I'm telling you right now,
it's advice I've been giving
for the last couple years,
I get more emails about
don't sell to the unsellable
and how it changed a
business that was doing
two million a year for 14 fucking years
and now they're doing
five 'cause they stopped
beating their fucking head against things
that aren't gonna happen.
It's friction.
Especially when it goes that old-school,
because we're now into
what I call religion.
It's an emotional decision.
They don't understand it,
they got four more years into retirement,
and I'm not gonna fucking
deal with that bullshit.
I don't fucking use, I barely
know how to use my phone.
Get out of here, you're gonna
fucking make me use this shit.
- So target the people that are--
- By the time I figured out
how to use it, I'll be slow.
You say it's gonna save
me time, no it's not,
I don't fucking understand
how to use this shit.
I can give you at all
because I live it, I see it.
- [Woman] And not just the
people who are coming in though
because we learn this, it's
the people who can say,
"Dad, dumb ass we have to go."
Because if it's just a kid,
they're not gonna listen to that one kid.
- Yeah, and eight out of 10 times
they don't even listen to the smart kid.
Back to beating your head.
Once I found out Sarah's in the business,
you go and have that meeting
and you figure out real quick
that Sarah has no say you're out.
And Sarah has no say eight of 10 times.
So like you're dealing
with a very small window.
The biggest boys and girls
and then family dynamics
where you get lucky two out of 10 times.
That's it, that's your business.
Which is great if you actually
know that and focus on that,
you can build a real business.
- And the main platforms
you'd say Facebook, LinkedIn?
- Facebook will really
work for the community.
You might want to start a Facebook group
of construction companies.
I'm very hot on Facebook groups.
That's what Facebook proper is becoming.
So starting a group and again,
notice where I'm about to go,
similar to what I gave you,
make it the Northeast
Construction Consortium,
that's the name of it.
Here's where we talk about
modernizing our industry.
See where I'm going?
All of a sudden you're
like on a non-profit,
not your own business.
And then if you don't
spam them with like oh,
the only reason you wanted me
in this group is to pitch your shit.
They're gonna find, I'm
telling you right now.
Bring value they will find you.
- [Man] Cause that's
what I don't wanna do,
I don't want to be like a pushy--
- So don't, so don't.
- [Woman] The people that they're doing
the projects for are the pushy ones.
They're forcing their construction guys
to use this app because
it's saving them time,
therefore saving them time on projects.
- [Man] Right, but I
would rather them do that,
not be the one that's you know---
- [Woman] So then he gets
the people, the projects,
the real estate people, the developers,
the incentive that hey,
this gonna save you time
and force your construction
guys to use it.
- You can definitely sell
through that channel.
- [Man] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Awesome, being in a
dual sided marketplace
and our audiences are very different
in what value props resonate with them.
So in thinking about creating content
is it creating content for each of these?
- [Gary] Both.
- Or finding a common thread that can--
- No, there's no common thread
between Republicans and
Democrats right now.
And that's what you have
in a two-way market,
drivers of Uber and Uber drivers
don't have a common thread.
- [Woman] They came from Uber.
- So you know.
- And so sorry to get more
specific on the business side,
someone who's like an enterprise account
like an Aramark or a Sodexo versa caterer
have really different
needs and the value props
resonate really differently with them.
So if we have like 10 of them
is it creating different
content for each level?
- Yes, yes.
- [Woman] From everything from long-form
through our ad content
is going to be different?
- Yes, and the way you target the ads
and inevitably where some
things over resonate.
So for example, your Instagram strategy
is gonna resonate much
more with the caterers
because they themselves are trying
to market on that platform.
Whereas the only place you
can get Aramark is on LinkedIn
or if you decide to go
the route of building
the food services number
one internal B2B podcast.
And again, this is why
this is such a home run,
you start the food
services podcast literally
and you email the Aramark
CMO and she's saying yes.
It's crazy, I can't, I'm gonna say,
this is why I like the
high school party analogy
because inevitably two
out of every three people
went to a high school
where somebody who wasn't
the most popular kid junior year
became the person that hosted the party
and became a lot more popular.
It's just something you can understand,
like oh my god, that's
right Ricky did that
and that's the same thing as
like you can't get in the door
at the number five at some
of these conglomerates,
but then you email cold on LinkedIn,
the number one CEO and their press person
or comms person's like oh yeah,
we want him on more podcasts.
And then when it's a literal Florida,
I mean we have a podcast show
on the VaynerMedia group
called the CMO podcast.
Just so CMOS keep running
through our doors.
So I'm eating the food I'm putting down.
- [Woman] Awesome and
yeah, there's not a space
that they're all gathering
to have those discussions
so we just create that.
- You mean in the individual cohorts?
- Yeah, or as a group
even 'cause event planners
and all of that, it's--
- [Gary] That group, but
that's different then--
- Exactly.
- Yeah, do not mix them.
It won't work.
If you look at the dynamics
of groups or forums
or communities, it needs to be specific.
It's why so many people are confused by,
what they don't understand
what I do with my content
where I do garage saleing and
wine and entrepreneurship,
they think that that's contradictory
to the advice I'm giving, as
a human it's your strength.
As a company it's your weakness.
- So I have a family business question.
My parents own a whole sale
cookie company in Mass.
I showed them your 4Ds
where you were talking
to someone in real estate
and aside from the swearing
they were like cool,
high school party, cool,
like let's go record softball
game or something locally
but we don't have the
manpower, blah, blah, blah.
We tried eCommerce and
it was great for data on
like where in the country
people like the cookies,
but shipping was a problem
because the cookies kept breaking.
We get accounts and they're
growing nationally slowly.
Penetration in New England and Northeast.
So how do we use social media
aside from being hyper local,
which is a given in New England,
but like just to get
interest for other people
elsewhere so they can ask
their stores in Florida--
- So Sonic restaurants,
which is a client ironically of Vayner,
but even if they weren't this would,
I don't know if you know this,
but for years they were
only in the South East
but they would run
commercials in North East.
- [Man] Cool, interesting.
- And so this is advice I'm giving you.
I've always thought that the
Sonic move on the QSR level
was always the smartest B2B
distributor and reselling move.
Like you could build up so
much demand on Facebook,
LinkedIn, and Instagram
in Arizona by making,
to prove my point I would
make a Diamondbacks cookie,
make it up and then only
market it in Arizona
to Diamondback fans and
just literally show,
if I was the other son
I'd be like watch this
and in a 100 days inbound
inquiries to carry it.
- [Man] So like manifest it--
- Manifest through execution.
That's why I said something
about The Secret the other day,
like fuck The Secret, you know that book?
Like you know and people got really mad.
They're like Gary, manifestation is real.
I'm like because you
did something behind it.
(laughing)
Like I also have a goal
it's called buying,
are you gonna say that
buying the New York Jets
was a manifestation?
No, yes I said it but it was
'cause I was doing things.
So yes manifesting through very tactical,
you could even target actual retailers.
You guys could thoughtfully
sit down and say okay,
in Minnesota there's this great family
gourmet chain of 11 locations.
Like if I was a wine
producer, just to give a comp,
I would try to get to Cappy's
or Martinelli's in Mass.
I tried to get to get to
Haskell's in Minnesota,
like you could get real thoughtful.
I mean you can get so crazy
when you actually make the cookie,
Martinelli's and Cappy's
are two big chains
in mass for liquor, you can literally
create a cookie called the cap.
Market the fuck out of it
and then just target ads
to employees of Cappy's
and inevitably they're
gonna like holy shit,
there's a fucking cookie called the cap,
we have to carry that.
I mean it's it's so scary what I know,
I can do anything with this model.
What do you want to happen?
It's just reverse engineering.
- [Woman] Can you do that for software?
- Of course.
- [Woman] Help me, how do--
- You have to understand
you know his is real easy
because you're dealing with a cookie
and you're talking about an environment
where the stores ROI is predicated on
bringing in new items, kicking out items,
things of that nature.
Him getting into stores,
what I just showed you,
I could do crazy uncomfortably.
The game that we'd have
to play is retention.
The game where I'd have to
really help him is retention,
because if I looked under the hood
his economics might not
even be that attractive
in opening an account that then kicks out
the product after 90 days.
- [Man] Need about six or seven accounts
to make a region worth it in our space.
- Now the good news is back to that,
I think I could get him
12 'cause then I lose six
and that's what I would do.
I'd like all right, we need in order
the 12 fucking mom and pops or one-offs
or six store units or da, da, da.
Software's tougher but far more lucrative,
that's why they're big businesses.
You know you've got to get in,
once you get in it's hard to
get out of even bad software.
It takes two, three years
which is why we all love
building SAS businesses.
Getting in is tougher,
but what you could do is
actually reverse engineer
every single business and decision maker.
You could actually spend,
I think people are so
worried about talking
that they're spending
no time on listening.
Your ability to create, I mean her ability
to literally create all 50 agencies
that are within driving
distance of her home
because that's just smart.
Like why get an account that's far away?
And then literally just
stalk AKA do homework
on the pain points and
words out of the mouth of,
like I mean she could possibly
and you know this especially
being an extrovert,
like her business may
come from the fact that
they're both Maverick fans.
She could make a Luka
Doncic reference in a post,
I mean that works on me you know so--
- [Woman] I was thinking
about how can I rename
a part of my product to be
like Diamondback lately?
- You know the thing there
is that's your business
where's like its a skew under his world,
so it gets a little trickier,
but I think the thesis
of reverse engineering
your target is again, I don't think,
maybe Nick you might have caught this.
There was this great moment
four or five years ago,
my team, me staying out here,
which I do once or twice
every couple months,
where I basically declared
I was gonna get popular in hip-hop
and everybody made fun
of me made fun of me.
Made fun of me and then I just
did it right in their face.
(laughing)
You can do it if your products good,
then you can do anything you just have to
understand how the Internet works.
So that's what I would
do in that scenario.
I'd also really, really,
really challenge you
to innovate on shipping.
You know I think one of the
things that I've noticed
with a lot of food products is that
they were half pregnant with
their execution on E-comm
and it's so imperative for
the growth of their business
long term that putting some money
and more importantly heart and head
behind actually trying to solve
it, instead of being like.
And family businesses love to do this.
- [Man] Yeah, they do that a lot.
- Yes they do and I think
that is super important,
because much like brokers,
retailers take way too much of the action.
You don't want them to have control
and you don't want
somebody to come along--
- [Man] Especially for a small business
one account can handle a
large percentage of your--
- Scary, scary.
- [Man] Cool, thank you.
- Let's keep it going.
Let's go free form, raise your hand.
Go ahead.
- So back to our other conversation,
with the auto generated content
we believe that humans and AI
should work in partnership,
because as you know marketing is emotions
and you buy on emotion--
- Couldn't agree more.
- So each of the posts you can edit them
and humanize them, right?
You can optimize them or whatever.
- And do you guys tell them that
that is the best practice?
- Yes, we do.
- Good, keep going.
- But we started doing it more
because one of the things I have
is I have all my interns as soon
as someone becomes a customer
or even becomes a lead,
they connect with them on LinkedIn for me
or follow them on Twitter so actually A--
- Watch.
- I can see that they
were pushing the button
and letting the content rip
and if you put garbage in,
it's garbage out, right?
- 100%.
- And I was like ugh guys,
this just basic 101 grammar sometimes.
- We believe in it so much,
we don't automate anything.
Even though we think that
that's inefficient and should,
but I've been so passionate
to build the religion of context,
not automated scale that if I did it now
now the company would
be thoughtful about it.
If I did it first it'd be like
everybody else in the world
and 99% of your clients and
we just met with Facebook,
99% of what celebrities do like
everybody wants automation.
Nobody actually wants to build
a meaningful relationship,
they just want the likes and the sales.
- [Woman] It's true.
- I'm aware.
- [Woman] I do have a secret.
- Go ahead.
- [Woman] Which is your team is using you.
- Phenomenal and I'm sure
like we hack with stuff,
but like the fact that
like I don't even know that
is the punch line, right?
- So the point is, is
that I saw them doing this
and then people actually
started asking me too
like how do we optimize it?
And so we do open office hours
every week for the public.
Anybody can come and for half an hour
we go through features
and we talk marketing
and blah, blah, blah.
So I was like you know what,
once a month I'm just gonna get on
and I'm gonna auto-generate
somebody's blog,
they can volunteer or I
can just grab somebody
and I'm gonna go in and
optimize each single post
and show them the trick to it.
And so we do it, it's great, everybody's--
- Yay, yep.
- And so we were trying to figure out
how can we improve that?
So right now, this ties in
to the podcast question,
this is a very visual thing, right?
And it takes time, you need to screen,
it's my time commitment, I
can't really reproduce it,
I can't even really--
- Well you can lay your
services on top of it.
- So we have an inkling idea
of this, tell me about this.
- I think you should tell the world
that it would be far more effective
for them to pay an extra $5,000
a month for post-production
before they post than
just hitting the post.
Sanan, who on our team
is using this product?
I wanna get the insight.
- [Sanan] May and Leshawn.
- Cool.
Let's find Rogoff I want to
just hear him talk for a second.
You know?
I think you would be stunned
if you went with this approach
and I understand why you wouldn't.
- [Woman] I want to.
- Hey, I know, let me give you the pitch.
Hey, how much is your product?
- [Woman] Starts at 50 but as customers--
- Understood, so give me the range.
- [Woman] 130,000.
- A month or 10,000 a month?
- [Woman] 10,000 a month.
- Cool.
50 to 10,000, right?
Cool.
Hey, you can use this at 100 bucks a month
and we're very proud of the product.
If you pay an extra thousand a month
that hundred a month
actually works like 2,000
instead of the 100 working like 30.
I genuinely believe that to be true.
How are using this tool?
- Well, a couple ways,
we're doing scheduling.
- That's okay.
- Scheduling's a big one on LinkedIn
just 'cause we can't natively
schedule on LinkedIn.
- Right.
- It also allows you to take transcripts
from videos that we have
and it pulls out quotes
that will potentially
perform off the platform.
So we'll take like a video
that we put on YouTube,
we'll run it through the platform,
we'll pull out like 10 quotes,
and we'll schedule 'em out
over the next five days.
- Understood and how'd you find it?
- It was--
- Do you remember?
- I think we posted
something on LinkedIn--
- Do you know the story?
- [Woman] I do, yeah.
- What was it?
- [Woman] You clicked
the thing on LinkedIn
that said oh, I wish there was an AI tool
that would create 30 or 40 posts
from content and I was like--
- Yay, awesome, thank you.
- They got so many shout outs.
I'm sure, awesome, thank you.
- We actually engineered
some of the shout outs too.
(laughing)
- I think you just roll with that.
I think you make that
part of the sales pitch.
If nothing, first of all--
- [Woman] Can you say it again real quick?
- Yeah, yeah.
Hey, super excited you're checking us out.
So look based on the way you
look like you're gonna do it,
I think you're gonna be 300 bucks a month.
Just FYI we have a
creative services overlay,
which does the post-production
that is actually the variable of success.
Our tool gets you to
third and a half base,
but the human created variable
from third and a half base
to home plate is so much more significant.
Now this may sound weird,
even though you're only
paying 250 a month,
our service for our
creatives and our strategist
and our copywriters is a
thousand a month in addition.
We're thrilled to have
you at 250 and we think
there's nothing that competes
for 250 in the market.
However, just on the record,
whether you do it and we
don't do it for a thousand
or you pay us to do it
for a thousand at 1,250
intuitively I feel like you're getting
$2,500 worth of value verses, excuse me,
at 1,000 you're getting
$2,500 worth of value
or excuse me, at 1,250, I
had to rate the percent.
You're getting $2,500 of value.
At 250 bucks we think you're
getting $350 worth of value.
So if you can afford it you can imagine
how that amortizes or
you still pay us 250,
but you better hire somebody
and pay them 40,000 a year
to post produce everything
'cause you can't imagine
the delta, here's three fucking versions
of me doing it by hand, that's the pitch.
- [Woman] Is this all recorded?
- Yep.
(laughing)
- [Woman] Awesome.
- That's the pitch.
- [Woman] That's super
money, thank you so much.
- You got it, it will work, here's why.
25% will hire you for it
and you'll start building
a VaynerMedia on top of it.
It won't be as efficient
as a SAS business,
but it'll bring up your ROI
and it's gonna work better,
it's gonna help your LTV.
20%, 20% are gonna do
it internally in a way
they wouldn't have done it
if you sold it differently.
They'll do it right, which is
40% more than you have now.
- [Woman] Winning.
- And again, back to
the specific industry,
it's still very like a
high-touch of a lot of visits,
and meeting and handshakes and
like how can we break into it
and layer in more digital
content to alleviate
some of our sales reps from having to have
so many face-to-face meetings?
- I think that won't,
unless you get people
to communicate via text
or screen times or things,
you won't eliminate it.
I think what content will do is
make your funnel much bigger.
- Okay, we do all of our support via text
and we have it on 24/7
so we're the ones responding
to any inquiry that's--
- So now you're talking more about
the DNA of the sales team?
- [Woman] Yeah.
- It goes back to the construction guys.
It's getting them to push for
more scalable communication.
Some of them are most naturally
comfortable in face-to-face.
There's many salespeople
who subconsciously,
subconsciously think going to meetings
is justifying their being.
- I mean a lot of times
it's their KPIs, right?
It's like how many meetings
and phone calls they have.
So adjusting those to be aligned with--
- Yeah, it's so funny a lot
of my biggest clients are like
Gary, you know I get
it but my team doesn't.
We believe in this and
I'm like change the KPIs.
If you believe in it and
you're the CEO, Sally,
make the bonuses predicated
on your marketing people
to spend 25% of Facebook.
I have a funny feeling
if their personal bonus
is tied to a requirement of
spending 25% of the money
on Facebook, like it's
unbelievable watching leaders
push the envelope on their employees,
to your point, which I'm glad
you picked up on so quickly.
Change the KPIs.
It's so fun to like, companies that bonus,
we don't really do that here,
but you have full control.
Can make people do
whatever the fuck you want.
- [Woman] You guys don't do bonuses here?
- We have a couple of
different things in place
for like the heads of the
offices and some of the Vayner,
I think the Sasha group is
taking a different approach
with James 'cause he
comes from that ecosystem.
I'm letting him do that with these guys,
so like we're starting to have some,
but bonuses scare me as a macro
because I'm worried about a disconnect.
I'm worried about Nick and I,
him being on a arbitrary bonus,
I mean some things are black and white,
but even that scares me
because if you're doing it
just completely on a financial KPI,
people's behaviors become so erratic
and often don't map to
the culture or the gray
or the long term that I'm trying to build
so it's inherently against it.
And then the only other way
to do it for me is subjective,
but then he's walking in
thinking he should get 22K
in bonus and I'm thinking
13 and that's fine
'cause that's not super big apart,
but literally I just had somebody
and this is a raise cycle.
They're walking in, they think
they deserve $100,000 raise
and I think they deserve a
$5,000 raise and that's real.
That literally just happened
and I'm like that's gonna be tricky.
I'm like yeah, I'll get
back to you fucking like.
(laughing)
I don't know where I'm,
literally walked out
like oh man, I got a
lot of thinking to do.
What's gonna happen here?
So you know.
- [Woman] We don't give bonuses either,
but that's because we haven't been able
to afford to in the budget.
- I get it.
- But it also seems to be working,
so I have of course a tons investors
were like what the hell, why don't you
have a bonus system for your sales team?
I'm like we need (mumbles)
- Yeah I mean investors are
Excel sheet, Goldman Sachs,
business school junkies.
They just think it's right.
It actually leads to
incredibly bad human behavior.
It just leads to, people have to live
and they have factored in
the max of their bonus.
First of all, people don't
know how to save money.
Like if you have an employee
who literally has an arbitrary
bonus between 15 and 50,000,
she's living with the 50,000 in mind.
Then it comes and you give her 26
'cause you had a bad year
or she was just okay.
She's like fuck.
She's like I have, my credit card bill's
not getting paid off,
like it's just crazy.
People don't factor real into theory.
I always go here when
I get in this mindset.
I always implore people to read
Marxism and communism on paper.
It sounds remarkable.
Every person at VaynerMedia would love it.
It's extremely socially liberal.
It just isn't inherently human.
Some things are better on paper.
And business became one to one-dimensional
and finally I see some
of the tide turning.
Starting to have EQ
and gray conversations,
but in the rise of finance and startup
it was run by an old boys club of
Harvard Business School
told me this, see ya.
Just not my thing.
- On the investor side we do some
specific marketing to investors.
- Smart.
- I was going to ask if you thought
that was a viable strategy or--
- It is the strategy.
I couldn't be more bullish on that
for somebody who's raising capital.
Always be putting out
content to raise capital
so that when you have to raise capital
you're on third base
not fucking, the dugout.
Super bullish on it.
- We actually took our investors emails
and integrate them through
Facebook as paid ads.
- I actually think the other
thing you guys could be doing
is already marketing for the exit.
- [Woman] Oh yeah.
- Like here's why, here's why.
You know it's never the wrong time
to take somebody grossly overpaying.
Like I've always said everybody
this is never for sale
and if it's for sale, quit.
But inherently there's
always a 1% chance in my head
I'm like well if Disney
realizes this creative machine
and they offer me three
billion dollars tomorrow,
it's a wrap 'cause it's just too much.
There's nothing I can like, you know,
I would trick Disney into
thinking nobody's gonna quit
and a lot of people would probably quit
'cause I've been telling 'em to quit.
But I'd fucking figure it out
because it's too big of
a number and it's just,
the Million Dollar Man's
right, everybody's got a price.
So like marketing now for
the exit is also a good idea.
- [Woman] I can't imagine that, can you--
- Having a good understanding
of who might want to buy you
and then making content about you in a way
that lends them to start putting seeds
to why they should buy you.
Running an article,
running a piece of creative
that is titled Why Food Service Companies
Should Own All Their Internal Tech.
And then subconsciously
like, humans are funny.
They're real funny.
The CFO of a board all of a sudden goes,
we should have our own internal tech.
Who do we use?
Quick, let's buy them.
(woman laughing)
That's what happens.
- [Woman] Yeah, it's true.
- So the building in New
Jersey I'm redeveloping
and I think Cosi in
there is food services.
Construction is supposed to be done
in the beginning of 2019.
They're going to move in
February of oh, excuse me, 2020.
How would go about marketing, like I want,
basically the buildings half-full
so about 70,000 square
feet of leasing to do.
- Central Jers?
- Yeah.
- And are you trying to
think about the notion of
how do you market to the
other businesses using Cosi
as like a gateway drug
to them considering it?
- Well I just kind of wanted
to get the word out there
because there's no food
services in the area.
I mean, there's no downtown,
people in the building bring their lunches
actually into the office and
I have some jankie grab and go
vending machines that I
took out of there and now--
- You think it's a value prop
and might be the reason
somebody considers to move.
- Exactly.
- Look I would pound and I
mean pound the 20-mile radius
of your company or this
location on LinkedIn.
I would pound the living shit out of it.
But one more time because I
want to give you good advice
and actually now I
remember what you answered.
You still believe it's
basically a localized transfer,
this is not somebody going
from Trenton to here?
It's not Bergen County to there?
It's not Ohio to there?
It is within that radius
is what your intuition is?
- [Man] Yeah.
- I would probably run two
cohorts of ads about the project
on LinkedIn against business
owners within a 15-mile radius
and then a separate one,
business owners in New Jersey
to get the same thing that
his family cookie business
found out by having E-comm,
which is like wait a minute,
there's random demand in Denver.
I think just running the ads
might give you some
insight and then please?
- [Man] What was the second one again?
- All of Jersey and again,
you've got Nick and others here,
Maribel, like they'll
help you kind of like
tie some of these ribbons
up that I'm putting down.
Like what did he mean by that
or how do I actually do that,
or on a follow up call like
we want to bring value,
but that's what I would do.
LinkedIn ads are expensive
'cause there's a floor,
it starts at $2 CPMs instead
of five cents like Facebook
or 10 cents like, but
it's very high-quality.
And organic without paid will work,
but when you post that hey,
the premiere central Jersey
office space is here now with,
you know even if you made it a commercial,
if you post that organic,
if you made a page
for that building or even
on your organic LinkedIn
that could hit somebody in Florida.
The reason you pay for the
ads is you get to get narrow.
I want you to do broad content
because it's just always a good idea.
It could lead to a
million different things.
Let me give an example, it could lead to
a third generation family
that doesn't have a succession
plan in a real estate empire
saying this kid seems
smart and he comes from
a pedigree of
multi-generational developers.
I'm gonna reach out to
him and see if he wants to
operate my business since I
have nobody to give it to.
Like it could lead to that.
Do you see where I'm going?
That's why content done
right always is a good idea.
It leads the things you're
not even thinking about.
You saying something thoughtful in a video
that was built to get people
in Dallas area to work with you
may lead to somebody in
Oregon reaching out to you
and saying don't do that, we
thought that was brilliant,
why don't you become the
back-end infrastructure for us
and you're like I did that,
I don't want to do that,
and they're like but we'll
do this and you're like
well that makes it
financially worth my time.
What I like about the
content is it creates
you to be open to things you
might have not even thought of.
That's the brilliance of
a volume creative model.
the reason I'm smart and
have all these insights is
'cause I've created a content machine
that led to me listening.
It looks like I'm talking,
it led to me listening.
- [Man] That's crazy.
- It is crazy.
- [Man] You should tweet that.
- It's a good one, I made
sure Dustin caught it.
(laughing)
All the talking has led
to a level of listening
that gives me such
profound consumer insights.
- [Woman] I have another question.
- Go.
- [Woman] So Nick was telling
us a little bit last night
about how you guys
stopped your strategy of
wasting time on annoying customers--
- [Man] RFP's over inbound.
- [Woman] Yeah, which I like.
Of course I love firing my customers,
but you know we're still trying
to figure out our funnel.
- Of course.
- [Woman] I'm still young enough
that every customer counts almost--
- No, no, that's right.
- [Woman] I actually abandoned
a couple people to upgrade,
but anyways, so there's
a lot of theories about
how many calls meaning touches or emails,
whatever it is, social touches
that it takes to get a customer.
It's 12, 14, like so if I had these leads
and they're qualified,
they're pre-qualified,
like taking that metaphor
into consideration
like really how much
time do I want my people
trying to reach somebody or
trying to convince somebody,
all we know that if we give you a demo
I have a 50% chance of closing
it, closing you all the way.
18%, sorry, I have an 18%
chance of actually closing you
as a sale and 50% of
closing you into trial.
So demo is good, I want
to get you on the phone
and say hey man, look at my thing.
But right now I know that it can take
like 12 reaches out to get that person.
- Because you're a sales
organization right now
not a marketing one, which is okay.
It's the story of 99.9% of SAS products.
It's just not what I
think the white piece is.
- [Woman] It's funny that you say that
because when we market it,
it actually happens
pretty instantaneously,
but it's the sales that
doesn't so you're 100% right.
- I'm aware.
(laughing)
- [Woman] And a good
example is on your thing
where I commented, every single person
who commented back has
had a demo this week.
- Makes sense.
- [Woman] But at the same
time I have all these leads
that we got from other
places and my sales team has
and I have names and email
addresses and phone numbers,
what do I do with those people?
Do I just all socially hunt them,
I guess that's what I should do.
Yeah, I answered my question then.
- Yep and what you want
to do is create one anchor
piece of creative that is your show
that becomes the catch-all
top to everything.
If everybody here leaves with a podcast
and that is really where
I'm going more than the vlog
then I've won because I
really think it will work.
Not everybody's gonna be good at it,
but when you do very narrow podcasts
you only need a very small
group of people listening.
This is not about making
The #AskGaryVee Show.
You get seven people to listen
and two become customers for a lot of you
it's going to be ROI positive.
Especially when you're a mature
level and have sales teams,
it becomes wildly positive.
- [Man] Same with doing an
interview on a smaller podcast
that might have like 300
views, that's 300 people like--
- I mean it's all I did.
We had a really famous
piece of, well famous.
We had a piece of content
that I, lemme rephrase.
There was a piece of content
that we made that I liked
that just showed all the, it
was just all these highlights
of me being on different
podcasts and YouTube shows
and it showed how many
views the video had.
107, 92, showing to
people like lower, lower.
Everyone's trying to get
on Joe Rogan's Podcast.
He doesn't want you.
You know like you've got a long way to go
before you get there, let's
get on the ones that you can
and more importantly let's host the one,
you're far more likely to host
and get somebody way above your skis
then you are to get on somebody's show
that's bigger than you.
- [Woman] We're getting
a lot of requests of
local entrepreneurship in Arizona,
it's like just starting to grow,
which is great from a thought
leadership perspective,
but it isn't like towards our industry.
That's still valuable--
- Especially if you
film it and then post it
and target against--
- [Woman] We'll do that now, yeah.
- I do more podcasts now than I used to
because I'm filming in
it's giving me content.
- [Man] So even for us podcast?
- Being on 'em is great
too if you record it
even if you're in your office,
like I literally record,
Dustin will record me on a
speakerphone doing a podcast.
Everything's about content.
- [Woman] What about discounts?
Like driving to drive
incentive with like 10%, 15%--
- It's sometimes a good
short-term sales mechanism
and always a brand detriment.
- [Man] How do you deal
with bad publicity?
What's the first thing you do?
- Address it publicly truthfully
including if I was wrong.
It's the only move,
there is no other move.
- [Man] There's no laying low?
- No, yeah there is, there is actually
that's absolutely true,
going into hibernation,
and waiting for the news
cycle to end is an option,
but unlike 1949 or 2000 for that matter
it lives on the Internet in
perpetuity and more importantly
here's the key of making a mistake.
Even if you're like on the
scummy side of a mistake,
America will reward you for the I'm sorry
and then you can just move forward.
Like you're such a young
kid without knowing
anything of why you're
asking that question,
without knowing anything just
going all, like this is crazy.
I said this the other day to somebody.
I believe that saying I'm sorry
is so revered in our society
that sometimes and this is not a joke,
I think about doing something on purpose
that's bad to just say I'm sorry
because I think net-net,
it would be better.
- [Woman] It's true, I trained
all my customer service team,
which is two people,
to always say I'm sorry
no matter what happens.
The first thing that
comes out of every email
and their mouth, I'm so sorry you had this
tough experience or whatever.
- Yeah, and then to that
point of like going from
smart tactic to deep intent is everything.
There was something,
somebody made a mistake here
very senior with another
employee who's not here anymore,
got a little ugly.
The person said they
were sorry in a nice way
and I was like okay and now in a month
I want you to do something
that makes them really know you're sorry.
So I want you to watch
everything they're about
and whether it's for
their daughter or for them
or donation to a charity
or giving a thousand bucks
to a GoFundMe of their friend's house
that burned down, now show them.
It really, look, for somebodies
who so good at scale,
pizzazz, sizzle, all this,
it's about the stake,
it's about the long-term,
it's about the truth.
It really works so to
answer your question,
especially if you're
going through it somewhat,
laying low is cool because
it allows you not to confront
and you get away with some short-term ROI,
but it's always there.
Saying you're sorry and
taking a little bit more
of a beating lets you go
fast for the next 80 years.
- [Man] But say you had like
zero cope ability and whatever.
- This will help you,
cope ability as like the
ability to cope with it?
The judgment?
- Yes, if something happened
and say you're getting blamed
for someone else doing something.
- Then you address that truth
even if you don't want to
call that person out by name,
if it's the truth and it's not the excuse
you came up with for
convenience for yourself,
which many people do
in that same scenario,
if it's a 100% the truth then you come out
and you reply in video form
where there's no confusion
in written form and you post that truth.
If it's 70% true and 30%
is the convenient of how
one wants to not take on accountability,
you need to come out with
the energy of 70 and 30.
- [Man] Yeah, great.
(laughing)
- And then if it's completely,
I thought you were going
in a different place,
I was hoping you were
so I'll say it anyway
'cause it's super interesting to me.
I've been thinking a lot about this.
Practice of losing and saying you're sorry
is an incredibly powerful game.
We are in such a judgment
society right now.
A complete lack of
interest of accountability
and a complete interest in blaming others
that the people that practice I'm sorry
and accepting their losses
are going to become monstrous.
Okay, go ahead sneak it in.
- Well, nah it's all good.
- Go ahead, go ahead.
- So I'm working on this
brand that you can only
purchase clothing, you can
only purchase it in New York,
but I'm trying to target people
who are traveling to New York.
- But you can only physically buy it here?
- [Man] You can physically buy it here.
- I think the number one
tactic is community management
on Twitter, searching
500 different key terms
that are indicators that
they're gonna be here,
because once they're here it's hard.
You need to win them the day before.
- [Man] Exactly.
So okay.
- Got it?
- [Man] Yep.
- Like literally 500
terms on search locked in,
going to New York, trip to New York,
my vacation, you know?
- [Man] Awesome, thank you.
(man whispers)
- That's really nice, thank you brother.
Thank you.
- You can target people who actually--
- [Woman] Thank you so much.
- You're welcome, thanks guys.
I'll see you guys later.
- [Man] Thanks Gary.
- Thanks.
Hey.
Hi.
- [Woman] Can I grab
you for a few minutes?
- [Gary] Yes, yes.
- [Woman] Three quick question for you.
- Where am I going?